[Musik]
haben sie es geht um die bis heute auch
so nicht umgehen
hier entlang
also ich begrüße euch hallo ihr lieben
heute gibt's ein ganz besonderes rezept
letztes jahr im sommer dann habe ich
euch diese panierten siga backstreet
gleichzeitig die man hier aufgeschnitten
jedenfalls gab sie letztes jahr zu
meiner ramadan reihe und ich sag's euch
die haben uns durch die ganze ramadan
zeit begleitet nicht nur uns sondern
auch meine zuschauer und es war auch
wirklich so bei uns im ruhrgebiet in
bochum wir waren in der gemeinde essen
bei familie bei freunden es gab immer
diese singlebörse panierten immer
wirklich und deswegen wollte ich euch
auch dieses rezept zu beginn zeigen
damit ihr das auch ganz normal dann
nachmachen können und die leute
anstecken könnte damit ich wünsche euch
jetzt ganz viel spaß bei dem video ja
gerne
wir starten mit der füllung und dafür
benötigen wir kartoffeln wie werde ich
gleich noch etwas klein schneiden
außerdem eine zwiebel etwas olivenöl
eine knoblauchzehe und tomatenmark und
an gewürzen salz pfeffer und edel süßes
paprikapulver optional nehmen wir später
noch ein wenig käse
die kartoffeln schneide ich hier noch in
kleinere stücke damit schneller durch
das und das wird das erste was wir
machen wir geben die kartoffeln in
kochendes wasser und kommen es so lange
bis es gar ist
also ihr solltet ihr natürlich nicht so
rein plumpsen lassen wir nicht sondern
immer schön piano nach ca 12 bis 15
minuten wenn die kartoffeln gar und das
erkennt ihr daran dass wenn ihr mit der
gabel einmal rein sticht das ihr euch
ganz leicht von der gabel fallen und
jetzt gehe ich das einmal schnell
abgießen und dann machen wir auch schon
weiter so die kartoffeln lasse ich jetzt
kurz ausdampfen und weiter geht's den
topf habe ich noch mal ganz schnell
sauber gemacht und gibt da jetzt mein
olivenöl rein und dann dünnste ich darin
zwiebeln und knoblauch an
jetzt sieht man dass die zwiebeln
richtig schön glasig gedünstet sind und
an der stelle gehen wir jetzt noch unser
tomatenmark mit dem sud wird jetzt auch
noch zusätzlich gebraten und dann geht
es auch schon weiter
das tomatenmark hat sich jetzt richtig
gut verbunden und es sind richtig
richtig tolle röstaromen entstand ich
liebe das immer tomatenmark anbrät oder
andünsten
jedenfalls machen wir jetzt weiter mit
unseren kartoffeln und die müssen wir
ich weiß nicht einfach eine gabel für
oder nimmt das was was bei euch am
besten klappt und einfach so ganz
unregelmäßig klein machen
wir müssten also kein kartoffelpüree
also nimmt jetzt keinen kartoffelstampf
und stand da drauf sondern das ist
wirklich nur so kleine richtig kleine
stückchen sind und wenn er so weit seit
gebt ihr einfach das was im topf ist mit
dazu und dann verrührt ihr das nochmal
gut miteinander
[Musik]
sobald sich das so einigermaßen
verbunden hat geben wir unsere drei
gewürze mit hinzu und dann noch mal
richtig kräftig alles umrühren und dann
ist die füllung eigentlich auch schon
fertig
und so ist die füllung eigentlich auch
schon fertig aber ich finde es mal ganz
lecker wenn man noch ein bisschen käse
da rein gibt natürlich vollkommen euch
überlassen aber probiert es gerne mal
aus
so die füllung ist jetzt schon mal
fertig die gebe ich jetzt kurz zur seite
und dann zeige ich euch schon die
nächsten zutaten für die weitere
verarbeitung benötigen wird diese news
kartei christ ganz dünn und den gibt's
schon fertig in dreiecken zu kaufen in
jedem türkischen oder arabischen
supermarkt für die tränke benötigen wir
milch neutrales öl und eier und
anschließend benötigen wir für die
panade noch paniermehl für die tränke
jetzt ganz einfach diese drei flüssigen
zutaten miteinander verrühren und am
besten in einer großen hohen schüsse
[Musik]
so und das war es auch schon an sobald
ihr das verrührt habt jetzt eigentlich
total schnell jetzt baue ich mir so eine
art station auf die habe ich links
meinen paniermehl rechts die tränke die
füllung nicht vergessen hier unsere
lächeln kartoffeln und jetzt braucht ihr
sohn pinsel und dann einfach immer ein
ewf tablett nehmen vor allem müsst ihr
auch dass joschka blatt unbedingt mit
dieser tränke vorher bestreichen
und sobald ihr das dann schön bestrichen
habt nehmt ihr euch ein esslöffel und
dann nehmt ihr die füllung und gibt wie
hier auf die lange und breite seite
und so bereiten wir uns jetzt alle vor
und ich habe gemerkt dass er mal ein
esslöffel von der füllung perfekt ist
für einen user blatt genau nach den uns
vorbereitet haben dann trinken wir das
erst
die reichen sind jetzt soweit alle
vorbereitet und jetzt kommt das was sie
eigentlich so besonders macht wir nehmen
uns jetzt 1 und toben darf in unsere
tränke einmal komplett was das kurz
abtropfen
dann nehmen wir das ins fannie mae
[Musik]
einmal von oben und von unten und dann
gehen wir sie auf ein backblech da habe
ich vorher noch wagt papier darunter
gelegt und so machen wir jetzt immer
weiter bis das backblech voll ist
so vorbereitet habe ich jetzt alles man
offen ist auch schon vorgeheizt 200 grad
ober unterhitze und jetzt kommt das
backblech für 20 minuten in den ofen
falls sie mich jetzt fragt wie kann man
das ganze auch frittieren oder in der
pfanne mit öl machen ja das geht
aber spart euch doch den schritt
packerin ofen dann trifft das auch nicht
so fett also so finde ich super super
lecker und haben sie auch sorgt nach
ungefähr 22 minuten sind die basics bei
mir jetzt fertig und sie müssen genauso
aussehen also goldbraun nicht heller und
nicht dunkler jeder offenbar anders
deshalb schaut einfach mal vielleicht
brauchen sie bei euch nur 20 oder 24
minuten so müssen wir ausgehen dann sind
sie perfekt und total knusprig
nacheinander warten
start ist noch nicht gern wollen ja
jedenfalls freue ich mich wenn euch das
rezept auch durch die ganze ramadan zeit
begleitet sowie uns im letzten jahr und
in diesem jahr natürlich auch wieder
schauten in die infobox für die genauen
mengenangaben und das hertha rezept das
habe ich euch ja schon gezeigt dass
verlinke ich euch gerne auch noch mal
genau das passt mir nicht auch super
wenn ihr das beim fastenbrechen zusammen
mit eurer suppe ist haben sie jedenfalls
freue ich mich wenn ihr meinen kanal
kostenlos abonniert damit ihr kein video
mehr verpasst und wir sehen uns ja dann
spätestens übermorgen tschüss nein
[Musik]